[Music]  welcome hollow TV viewers to the  infamous planet of sandia home to the  relentless superstar game mode in just a  few minutes we'll be watching the  semi-final match up between Kane  corporation and the defenders of cantore  but before we start let's review how the  game is played first our clones only  have a short time to gear up and choose  their weapons then a superstar is  randomly chosen on each team the  superstar must survive until the end of  the round then rush the central point on  the map  [Applause]  of course surviving is easier said than  done oh this integrated each round is  worth 1.5 points and you've won the game  [Applause]  don't forget to join us nicely on sign  our key TV this week for the spandy and  world championships until next time  folks  [Music]  close things